right now we want to get straight to
july 4th travel and the trouble that
millions of americans can expect this
weekend triple a predicts around 48
million people will travel for this
holiday that's just one million shy of
pre-pandemic levels now that spike in
demand seems to be overwhelming the
airlines and the airports more than
twenty thousand flights twenty thousand
have been delayed this week alone that's
a lot of people stranded and a little
irritated at the same time gas prices
are still close to record highs
averaging just under five dollars a
gallon errol barnett is standing above
interstate 395. yep he's on an overpass
in downtown in downtown washington ed i
mean errol see ed
sorry about that see
errol i know who you are errol it's
really good to see you how's it looking
there
hey look ed o'keefe is not a bad person
to be mistaken for i can tell you this
gail good morning to you it is busy busy
busy out here on the roads thankfully
though you see traffic behind me is
moving but triple a estimates that in
many metropolitan cities around the
country folks will be trying to get out
of work early this afternoon so you'll
see peak congestion this afternoon in la
chicago seattle
and houston it's also the busiest day
for air travel this weekend but as we've
been reporting these flight disruptions
are really frustrating passengers and
pilots alike
less flights more crowded
and people are testing our flight is
delayed and so basically we're going to
miss our second flight the planes are
full absolutely full as americans face
hundreds of flight cancellations and
thousands of delays delta airline
staffers are voicing their own
frustration we want to make sure that
every delta passenger gets to every
destination in the safest most on-time
fashion as possible off-duty pilots hit
the picket line nationwide thursday
demanding wage hikes amid ballooning
work hours and rampant service
disruptions typically flying accounts
for about eight to nine percent of the
folks traveling this year it's only
seven percent triple a spokesman andy
gross tells cbs news travel headaches
and skyrocketing prices are likely
deterring americans from flying the
average lowest cost for airfare is up 14
percent from last year at 201 dollars
per ticket
meanwhile the number of americans
expected to drive for the holiday 42
million is an all-time record what's the
headline for your fourth of july
forecast and what it tells us about
where we are as we
move through the pandemic it appears
that the urge to get out and go is
overwhelming these high prices for
everything aaron lyon his wife liz and
their nine-year-old daughter angelina
are in the middle of a nearly two-week
long road trip the montana natives are
headed for mount rushmore and say the
drive is worth the price family time is
more important making memories and
taking her out to see the country
especially around fourth of july
now it's worth noting that gas prices
have pulled back from their five dollar
record highs last month that's welcome
news for drivers and yesterday delta ceo
issued an apology for what he admits is
unacceptable cancellations and delays
still the airline has reduced its daily
departures by about 100 starting today
so a lot of excitement about the weekend
and anxiety about what may go wrong nate
prepare for some delays and have some
patience that's for sure errol thank you